this is the Olympus e6 20 it's a pretty
good entry-level digital SLR for 700
bucks you get a camera that does pretty
much everything that you would expect in
an SLR has a decent lens and takes
pretty good pictures in most
circumstances let's start with the
sensor inside this camera is a twelve
point three megapixel image sensor it's
about half the size of a 35-millimeter
frame of film now most digital SLRs
nowadays are have sensors that are
bigger than that but this is pretty good
and it's a lot larger than most
point-and-shoots
what that means is you'll be able to
take much better pictures because the
individual pixels in the sensor are
actually larger on a larger frame sensor
than they are in a really tiny one that
means less noise and better low-light
sensitivity at least in theory I say in
theory because the e6 20 doesn't
actually do all that well in low-light
situations if the room is really dark it
has a hard time focusing and it won't
take really good pictures if you crank
up the ISO level beyond about a thousand
the images start to look really grainy
which is typical of cameras with much
smaller sensors the lens that comes with
this kit is not bad it's a 14 to 42
millimeter zoom lens it's not the
fastest lens in the world and it's got a
kind of lightweight plastic II feel to
it but it's a versatile lens and will do
you well in a lot of situations the body
of the camera is also kind of plastic
and lightweight feeling that's a good
thing if you're carrying it around in
your bag but it might not be the most
durable thing so don't drop it
I dropped my last Olympus and it was DOA
and that was a drop of just about 12
inches which more solidly built cameras
will survive there's another feature
about this camera that I really like
which is that it has this flip out
swiveling LCD screen and that's really
good because like other modern SLRs you
can compose on the screen instead of
looking through the viewfinder and with
the swiveling LCD that means you can tip
it down so that if you need to hold the
camera over your head or you want to put
it down by your feet to shoot you can
still look at the screen and be able to
see what you're doing one downside of
the e6 20 is that even though it has a
live view function so you can compose on
the LCD
it does not have the ability to shoot
video and that's sort of a mystery
because most cameras nowadays that have
the live view function also have video
shooting all in all this is a pretty
good value for an SLR it's not gonna
please the photo enthusiasts and if you
have a lot of experience shooting with
this kind of camera
you're gonna want something much more
capable like a Canon or Nikon but if
you're new to SLR photography and you
don't want to spend a lot of money the
e6 funnies are really good choice